with the war in the ukraine intensifying
many european countries are attempting
to wean themselves off russian gas and
seek other trade partners and energy
sources the government of the democratic
republic of congo is in talks with an
australian energy giant to create the
world's biggest hydropower dam and
provide green hydrogen for a global
market that's a potential energy source
which is climate neutral but there are
questions about where this would leave
local people in the drc whose energy
needs are still unmet
jonas gerdin was in matadi close to
where the grand inga dam is planned and
he sent us this report
matadi in western dlc is the hometown of
glory pansu
[Applause]
he's the president of the country's
association of pharmacists and he's out
canvassing his members
again and again he hears the same
complaint
the lack of a stable electricity supply
a power cut to stop the ventilator
and the cooling system is also down
many medical products
need continuous cold temperatures for
their storage
but the chain of cooling cannot be
maintained and guaranteed
a power cut recently took out these
refrigerators at one of the pharmacies
hemi cell is a blood substitute if not
properly cooled it can cause
complications so it was thrown
why power outages are still a fact of
life for people in matadi
the country's biggest hydroelectric dam
inga is located just a short distance
upstream on the massive congo river
completed between 1972 and 1982 the two
inga dams alone account for 70 percent
of the country's power
most of the drc's power is hydroelectric
but just one in five people have access
to electricity
hamere kawende is service manager at the
dams
the population of the democratic
republic of congo
has almost tripled
and we are now approaching 100 million
people
the power generated by inga1 and inga ii
as they are currently installed is not
enough we need to press on with angular
3.
plans to build africa's biggest
hydroelectric plant have been
circulating for decades
now fortescue future industries an
australian company is in talks with the
country's president
the river congo would be redirected to
flood the bundy river valley storing
water behind a huge concrete wall
the plan has the potential to increase
power generation 25 fold but a recent
presentation explains fortescue's
motivation it wants to use the
electricity to produce green hydrogen to
sell on the world market
apollinari nusoka is the coordinator of
a local congolese development ngo he is
well aware that europe wants to reduce
carbon emissions and dependency on
energy imports from russia he's not
convinced fortescue's offer will benefit
the drc
most of the energy will be used to
produce hydrogen
that's the concept of the center and the
periphery everything that's produced
here will be brought to the center to
the west where they are facing the
challenge of the energy transition
and they think that they need to acquire
hydrogen
but we don't think that we've already
covered the electricity needs of our
country
there is a different view in kinshasa
the capital of the drc
alexi cayembe di bampende
is the special advisor in charge of
infrastructure to the president
he sees the dam as a motor of the
country's industrialization
he has a blunt answer to those who want
to supply electricity to all remote
areas
even if we're going to install
electricity at every
household
if the people don't have a job they want
to be in a position to pay that
electricity so we're looking at a
situation where
that the electricity itself
can
boost
the local economy
back in matadi there's only one thing
for sure for motors of the local economy
like glory panzu
power cuts are a fact of life for
businesses like his
for some analysis of the plans in the
drc i'm joined now by brian comanze an
independent energy analyst based in
south africa and he joins us from
johannesburg ryan welcome to dw news
africa now can we begin by getting your
thoughts on uh the statement from the
president's special
advisor he says the plan is not
intended to supply electricity to people
in the whole of drc so who is it for
uh thank you yes so there is a increased
demand
for
production of hydrogen
particularly in industrialized nations
policy shifts within the eu in
particular have driven an interest in
investments in the production of
hydrogen as a fuel which may and at a
future point in time replace the need
for lng gas
used for either
mainly for electrification but it does
have some other
applications as well including transport
so
there's not much use not much demand at
the moment in africa for hydrogen so
those hydrogen investments are most
likely
going to be for europe and a particular
drive from this obviously coming as a
result of the the tensions within the
conflict between ukraine and
russia
which has sent gas prices soaring
but essentially
this will be generating power
is there a way that this electricity can
also be distributed to citizens in the
drc for domestic use not just going out
see yes and so the challenge
unfortunately historically has been in
southern africa that
mining
corporations typically multinationals
have
fronted the money or
leveraged governments to put the
investment in for power stations and if
we visualize it like a body they have
put the transportation from these
massive generators that they've invested
in
the arteries go into the mines and heavy
industry uh very minimal heavy industry
outside of south africa
but definitely a lot of mines in drc
zambia among others
and then veins where they do exist goes
into
major towns and cities and largely would
provide electricity which benefits
largely wealthy residents
and and
government buildings and a few
um small industries
so that has been the historical trend
and unfortunately uh the situation drc
it is much the same the grandinger
project has held a lot of present
promise it's a massive infrastructure
project that the potential capacity for
that dam is tremendous but the financial
arrangements that have been structured
um to finance the grand inga have meant
that mining capital has been prioritized
and it's unlikely
we have already seen the communities
have not been privatized it's unlikely
that that will change unfortunately in
the short term
now there are already two inga dams
which are operating well below capacity
what's to say that this third one will
deliver on what it promises
yes so the
challenge of providing reliable stable
electricity that is also affordable to
both residents and industry alike is
very much tied to building a capable
state within the drc
unfortunately
the the two
ingo one and inga 2 projects you
mentioned as well as the aging
transmission infrastructure have
been the result of poor in investment
planning from government and also lack
of lack of regulation lack of
implementation of policy this has been
an issue and also the
the over-indebtedness this is intimately
tied to the over-indebtedness of the drc
um and and
the unfortunate position uh if not uh
almost criminal position it it finds
itself in um historically ever since the
assassination of patrice lumumba
brian can you sum up what a more just
model of power generation would look
like
okay
great so i think uh ingerdam is uh is
actually an an excellent case study
of some of the central problems within
within africa when it comes to
infrastructure finance
um is that at the moment
uh you know a lot of the finance for
anger comes from the world bank and it
has been tied to particular reforms that
have resulted in the liberalization of
the electricity sector in the drc and
yet we see in other parts
of the world in south africa in in in
china in other brazil
um that major rural electrification in
particular you know large part of the
dlc is rural um has been fronted by
public finance
um and that it's it's typically done so
because building transmission
infrastructure in rural areas is very
costly and it's unlikely that low-wage
agricultural workers
and and and where there's small
industries as well but those residents
are will be able to pay the cost of
fronting that infrastructure that's one
of the reasons why you don't see
um the power lines connected to these
villages but you do see them connected
to mines so
in order to make this just we need a
regime that
cross-subsidizes
there needs to be a tax regime it needs
to be strong institutions that can also
regulate um the planning of
how infrastructure is developed
and that is all intimately tied to
building a capable state within the drc
without that there is no hope for the
just transition there is no hope of
building an equitable
energy industry they also need to you
know the drc is has home to some of the
most precious minerals on earth
and that they've been reported on after
report year after year about the amounts
of illicit financial flows that have
flowed out of the congo and so one of
the ways to curb that is to have an
adequate tax collection regime which is
tied again to
a capable state which can help
redistribute some of those resources to
those who need it
right
okay brian comanzi an independent energy
analyst based in johannes johannesburg
many thanks for speaking to us
thank you
so big business big finance and big
power generation obviously come with
strings attached and they're of limited
value for the small-scale power user in
the drc
now even where communities are on the
grid supply is patchy but could there be
another way let's take a look at
small-scale power generation with a
project that has transformed life in a
small community ensuring the provision
of vital services in eastern drc
not your usual none
this is sister alfonsine sisa in her gum
boots and white helmet she spends most
of her day here managing this local
power plant it took her three years to
find the finances and build this
hydroelectric plant alongside bible
studies she earlier trained as an
electrical engineer
the convent needed an electrician
a technician who could help
they saw in me the talent of electrical
engineering
so they offered me an opportunity to go
study the technology
that's where it all started
constant outages and deep frustration
with the lack of power inspired sister
alvancine to start raising funds in
2015.
now the hydroelectric plant lights up
her local community including her
convent the local church a health clinic
and two schools
all free of charge
with the electricity we produce for the
school we can train young people
and with the power that we supply to the
hospital
we feel that we serve the whole
population because we are there for the
poor
and it is in the hospital that we meet
people from poor backgrounds
at the local hospital
this transformation has been crucial
we sometimes had to spend a whole night
without electricity at the hospital
and you can understand the importance of
power at night in a hospital
it was difficult going without
electricity and it was like a
resurrection when our neighbours helped
us by supplying the power we need
[Music]
without sister alfonsina's determination
her local community would have just a
few hours of power per week
now they're free of the problems that
plague the rundown and mismanaged
national generating system